in the last video we proved that the sum
of all of the positive integers up to an
including n can be expressed as n times
n plus 1 over 2 and we proved that by
induction what I want to do in this
video is show you that there's actually
a simpler proof for that but it's not by
induction so well so it wouldn't be
included in that video but I'll show you
that it exists so you know that
induction isn't the only way to prove it
so we're defining we define that
function s of n as the sum of all of the
positive integers up to and including n
so this is equal to by definition 1 plus
2 Plus 3 plus all the way to plus n
minus 1 plus n so it's the sum of all of
the integers up to and including n this
is how we're defining it well we can
rewrite it again we can say that the sum
s of n this is we can just rewrite the
same thing but we could rewrite it in a
different order we could say that this
is the same thing as n plus n minus 1
plus n minus 2 plus all the way down to
all the way down 2 plus 2 plus 1 now
what does this do for us well we can
actually add these two rows if we add s
of n plus s of n we're going to get 2
times 2 times this sum so we're just
adding on the left and then we can also
add on the right so we're just adding
this sum twice but what's interesting is
how we're going to add it we're going to
add this term to this term this term to
this term because we're really just
trying to add these two things and we
can pick any way we want to add them so
1 plus n so 1 plus n is going to be is
going to be n plus 1 and then we're
going to add do it in pink 2 plus n
minus 1 so what's 2 plus n minus 1 let
me write it over here 2 plus n minus 1
the same thing as 2 plus n minus 1 which
is the same thing as n plus 1 2 minus 1
is just 1 so this is also going to be n
plus 1 and then this term over here 3
plus n minus 2 or n minus 2 plus 3 once
again that's going to be
n plus-1 and you're going to do that for
every term all the way until you get
over here n minus one plus two that's
also going to be n plus one that's also
going to be n plus one and then finally
you have n plus one right over here plus
n plus one so what's this whole sum
going to be well how many of these n
plus ones or do we have well we have n
of them for every term in each of these
sums so this is one two three count all
the way to n you have n of these terms
so you have n n plus ones so if you add
something to itself n times or view if
you have something n times right over
here this is really just this is exactly
equivalent to n times n plus one so two
times that sum two times the sum of all
of the positive integers up to including
n is going to be equal to n times n plus
one so if you divide both sides by two
we get an expression for the sum so the
sum of all of the positive integers up
to an including n is going to be equal
to n times n plus 1 over 2 so here is a
proof where we didn't have to use
induction it's really kind of a pure
algebraic proof